Of all the dark songs by the band Nirvana and, there are a lot to choose from, the most disturbing to me is
Polly, the sixth track of their album,
Nevermind, an acoustic song, a quiet song, about the rape and torture of a teenage girl
Told from the perspective of the rapist
It's a hard song to talk about, harder because it's based on a real incident in 1987,
Gerald Friend, after being paroled early from a similar conviction in 1960,
abducted a 14 year old girl after leaving a concert, brought her back to his mobile home,
and repeatedly raped her and tortured her with a blowtorch, while she was suspended from a pole.
Yeah, it's horrific.
It's also right in the center of one of the best selling albums of the 1990s.
An album that enjoyed
mainstream success
Cruelties like those detailed in Polly are so
heart-rending that the instinct is to turn away.
The truth of violence like that is easily
repressed, forgotten, avoided,
but Kurt Cobain couldn't bear that.
In addition to exploring his own fears and anxieties in Nirvana's music,
he was also a vocal feminist who repeatedly spoke out against sexism and violence against women,
especially sexual violence.
It doesn't seem like much but you know, we raised like
$50,000 from the Bosnian rape victims, you know, and that's a lot more than we could have done
griping about it and talking about it in interviews and like maybe putting out a fanzine and you know
There's nothing wrong with doing stuff like that. But you know, we're using our, we're using the tools that we've, we have, you know.
Cobain did more than speak.
Nirvana played that benefit concert for Bosnian rape victims and in the lighter notes to incest aside,
Cobain instructed sexists not to buy Nirvana albums or come to the shows,
putting morals before money.
But though Cobain's views were inherently political,
His genius was artistic,
and what an artist can do is different than what an activist or a politician can do.
Art, especially music, impacts us emotionally.
It strikes at the core, and as a result, has a unique power to expand our empathy,
which is why the perspectives of Polly is so shocking.
But before I get to that, let me talk a little bit about the structure of the song.
I came to Nirvana pretty late.
I had just turned 3 when Nevermind was released
But I didn't really start listening to their music until a couple years ago.
And the two things that surprised me most were
One, the poetic brilliance of Cobain and, two, the catchiness and simplicity of the songs
and you don't get much simpler than Polly.
Composed in E minor, the chord progression is just the same: E minor, G, D, C for the verses.
Over and over again then
Then G5, B flat 5, D5, E5 for the choruses.
In the chorus, an unobtrusive bass enters on the low end and Cobain adds a vocal harmony on a high end.
Don't cut yourself.
I want some help.
To please myself.
There are no drums in the song besides one cymbal crash at the start of each chorus,
Oh and there's a bass break after the second chorus that lasts all of 9 seconds before the repetitive sequence starts up again.
So, Polly is basically Cobain and his guitar.
A gentle, catchy  melody and vocal.
and the effect of this restraint is a feeling of closeness, of intimacy, authenticity.
The feeling is heightened even further by the equipment.
On Polly, Cobain played Estela guitar bought for
$30 at a pawn shop.
"It barely stays in tune", he told Guitar World in 92.
"In fact,
I have to use duct tape to hold the tuning keys in place."
The flat plucky sound
removes any polish that could mediate between, and ultimately, divide
musician and listener.
Polly is a song designed, in other words, to give Cobain access to your head.
The question, is once he's in there,
what does he do?
The surprising and profound choice Cobain makes in Polly, is to make the
protagonist of the song, the intimate singer: the rapist.
This becomes very clear after just the first two lines.
Polly wants a cracker
I think I should get off her first
We are inside the mind of this vile man,
Carried along in the stream of his consciousness.
In each verse he reports what's happening with an amused detachment,
that is somehow more scary for its lack of emotion.
Cobain's vocal is aloof yet mesmerized.
Cobain routinely downplayed the importance of his lyrics.
But, don't buy it.
While it may be wrong to look for hidden meanings and things like that, his journals reveal a fascination
with language and word play.
The chorus of Polly is made up of fragments of images and sentiments
that simulate perfectly the chaotic flux of thinking.
You can see desires, regrets, cries for help, cruelty
self-deception, righteousness,
All momentarily bobbing to the surface, and then,
the animalistic final thought dictating this man's actions:
Please myself.
If you're being carried along by the rapist's stream-of-consciousness, in the verses, in the chorus,
you're drowning in it.
Haven't you?
Let me take a ride, cut yourself
I want some help,
Please myself
In a way that only music can, Cobain forces an emotional identification with evil,
to stop us from
suppressing this brutality.
evading it.
He makes it our own. It's a deeply distressing experience,
but it's also a motivating one.
"The problem with groups who deal with rape is that they try to educate women
about how to defend themselves", Cobain told NME in 91.
What really needs to be done is teaching men
not to rape.
Go to the source and start there.
With a catchy tune and a $30 guitar,
That's just what he does.
Hey everybody, thank you so much for watching and thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring this episode.
You could use Squarespace, if you don't already know,
to make sharp beautiful websites for anything you might need,
a personal site, a wedding website, a site for your business, for your photography portfolio
Whatever.
Their design team has crafted templates that work on computer browsers and on mobile,
and they switch perfectly
between the two, which is really important.
You can integrate your own photos and videos with just a few clicks
You can even link your social accounts so that you can auto post to Twitter and Facebook
All from within Squarespace.
Head over to Squarespace.com for a free trial and when you're ready to launch
Go to squarespace.com/Nerdwriter
to support this show.
You get 10% off your first purchase.
Thanks, guys. I'll see you next time.